worse happiness in terms of stages is on
three and four no Take that tension you
can be happy at any stage or unhappy
but I think that if you are at a stage
where you get agency over how your
feelings are generated and to some
degree you start doing this when you
leave a dollar stance I believe that you
understand that you're in charge of your
own emotion to some degree and that you
are responsible how you approach the
world that it's basically your task to
have some basic hygiene how in the way
in which you deal with your mind and you
cannot blame your environment for the
way in which you feel but you live in a
world that is highly mobile and it's
your job to choose the environment that
you thrive in and to build it and
sometimes it's difficult to get the
necessary strengths and um the energy to
do this and Independence and the worse
you feel the harder it is
but it's something that you learn
there's also this thing that we are
usually incomplete right I'm I'm a rare
mind which means I'm a mind that is
incomplete in ways that are harder to
complete so for me it might have been
harder to initially to find the right
relationships and friends that complete
me to the degree that I become an almost
functional human being
uh oh man the search space of humans
that complete you is an interesting one
especially for your shabach that's an
interesting because talking about Brute
Force search in chess
yep I wanna I wanna I wonder what that
search tree looks like
I think that my rational thinking is not
good enough to solve that task a lot of
problems in my life that I can
conceptualize as software problems and
the failure modes are bucks and they can
debug them and write software that take
care of the missing functionality
but the stuff that they don't understand
well enough to and uh to use my
analytical reasoning to solve the issue
and then I have to develop my intuitions
and often I have to do this with people
who are wiser than me and that's
something that's hard for me because I
don't have I'm not born with the
instinct to submit to other people's
wisdom yeah
so what kind of problems are we talking
about this is stage three like love
I found love was never hard
then
fitting into a world that most people
work differently than you and have
different intuitions of what should be
done ah
for empathy
um it's also
Aesthetics when you come into a world
where almost everything is ugly and you
come out of a world where everything is
beautiful I grew up in a beautiful place
and as a child of an artist yeah and um
in in this place it was mostly nature
everything had intrinsic Beauty
and everything was
built out of an intrinsic need for it to
work for itself you know everything that
my father created was something that he
made to get the world to work for
himself and I felt the same thing and
when I come out into the world and I am
asked to submit to lots and lots of
rules I'm asking okay when I observe
your stupid rules what is the benefit
and I see the life that is being offered
as a reward that's not attractive
when you were born and raised in
extraterrestrial Prince
in a world full of people wearing suits
so it's a it's a challenging integration
yes but it also means that I'm often
blind for the ways in which everybody is
creating their own bubble of
wholesomeness almost everybody and
people are trying to do it and for me to
discover this it was necessary that I
found people who had a similar shape of
Soul as myself so passive these are my
people people that treat each other in
such a way as if they're around for each
other for eternity
how long how long does it take you to uh
to detect the geometry the shape of the
soul of another human to notice that
they might be one one of your kind
um sometimes it's instantly and I'm
wrong and sometimes it takes a long time
you believe in love at first sight yeah
yes but I also noticed that I have been
wrong
so
sometimes I look at a person and I'm
just enamored by everything about them
and sometimes this persists and
sometimes it doesn't and I
I have the illusion that it damn much
better at recognizing who people are as
they grow older
but that could be just
cynicism no no it's not cynicism it's um
it's often more that I'm able to
recognize what somebody needs when we
interact and how we can meaningfully
interact
it's not cynical at all you're better at
noticing yes I'm much better I think in
some circumstances and understanding how
to interact with other people then I did
when I was young so that takes us it
doesn't mean that I'm always very good
at it